A craftsperson can begin
assembly by creating the
valve that covers the
intake hole.
She installs a rounded
length of wire, stapling
it in such a way as to
create enough tension for
the wire to act as a
spring.
This step completes the
interior of the bellows.
She starts by wrapping a
pre-cut piece of locally
sourced sheep's leather
around one handle and
attaching the leather in
place with small nails,
carefully hammering a
series of closely spaced
upholstery tacks at
regular intervals.
The artisan can now
attach the second half by
repeating the operation
on the other side of the
leather. The artisan
uses a section of pre-cut
leather to form the
hinge necessary for the
proper functioning of
the bellows.
The size, position and
tack pattern must all be
precise in order for the
tool to open and close
smoothly and easily.